Eric Caffrey Bala goon and Yaffe of a
lagoon are cofounders of the Huey P
Newton Gun Club in Dallas they see
themselves as revolutionaries and
teachers patrolling black neighborhoods
openly armed this particular weapon is a
shotgun and what what we use this weapon
as is a political tool to organize the
masses of people it represents a sense
of security it represents a sense of
safety they say they're fighting police
brutality and racism and they claim
membership is on the rise in the wake of
the attack that killed five police
officers do you condemn the attack I
can't say I condemn him but what I can
tell you when fatica Lee is that I
understand why he did it he did it
because he wanted to see a meeting into
police brutality and murder of the
people not just black people but Brown
people poor people across the United
States on Muraki
why is it that other countries are not
having this problem why is it these
other countries are not having this
problem we think that America has the
blood of its citizens on his hands he
says Mica's Xavier Johnson the 25 year
old suspected of carrying out the
shootings was a familiar face but not an
official member of the group just like
us he wanted to see change in his city
and ultimately the world what do you
think he's achieved he's put the
spotlight here on the city of Dallas the
contradictions that he potentially
exposes the fact that black brown and
poor people are so disenfranchised in
this city that it took an individual
what an assault weapon to bring this
issue to a front to the forefront that
is so sad to say they took that stuff do
you feel that similar attacks may happen
I hope that America itself took heed
- what happened here in this city and
really consider the direction it is
going as a nation I hope that President
Obama and his administration will before
he leaves office and even his successor
takes he to know that they must do
something about this particular issue of
police brutality which we says he is on
for police terrorism the authorities
believe he was a lone wolf but the
attack has exposed a deepening division
across America
Bedelia Lynch Sky News Dallas Texas